As traumatized fans of Game of Thrones know
all too well, Lady Catelyn Stark was shockingly
and brutally slain in the penultimate episode
of season three. But with the show's final
season about to arrive, fans are once again
wondering: could she somehow still be alive?
On the surface, it sounds impossible. After
all, the infamous "Red Wedding" scene couldn't
have been more clear about the deaths of Catelyn,
her new daughter-in-law Talisa, and her son
Robb Stark, the erstwhile King in the North.
After being betrayed by Lord Roose Bolton
and Lord Walder Frey who had been secretly
conspiring with the villainous House Lannister
to destroy the Starks Robb, Talisa, and Catelyn
were all stabbed to death in horribly graphic
fashion. There's no doubt about it: she was
very definitely dead.
But is she going to stay dead?
"look who knows so much! Well, it just so
happens that your friend here is only mostly
dead. There's a big difference between mostly
dead and all dead."
First, it's important to remember that people
come back from the dead in Game of Thrones
all the time. Both Jon Snow and Beric Dondarrion
have done it thanks to the kiss of life from
the fire god known as the Lord of Light. And
then on the slightly less happy side of things,
the Night King has been resurrecting the dead
for eons, forming a zombie army that includes
not just giants, but a giant dragon.
So it's theoretically possible that Catelyn
could be brought back. But more importantly,
it's actually already happened… in the books,
that is. Author George R. R. Martin, who wrote
the fantasy novels that form the basis for
Game of Thrones, resurrected Catelyn not long
after the Red Wedding, with Beric Dondarrion
surrendering his own immortality in order
to return Catelyn to the land of the living
as the vengeful Lady Stoneheart.
For her part, actress Michelle Fairley told
Entertainment Weekly that Catelyn would not
be returning regardless of what happened in
the books.
"Yeah, the character's dead. She's dead. You
respect the writers' decision. I knew the
arc, and that was it. They can't stick to
the books 100 percent. It's impossible…
they only have 10 hours per season. They have
got to keep it dramatic and exciting, and
extraneous stuff along the way gets lost in
order to maintain the quality of brilliant
show."
Still, people associated with Game of Thrones
have been known to lie in the past in order
to prevent spoilers. Most famously, for example,
the folks at HBO swore up and down for a year
that Jon Snow was actually, really dead for
good after being betrayed at the end of season
5. Naturally, of course, he was back on his
feet in season 6.
Plus, even some of the show's stars have publicly
hinted that more major characters would be
also brought back from the grave on the side
of the Night King. In 2017, Nikolaj Coster-Waldau,
who plays Jaime Lannister, told Esquire
"The fear is that I would be turned into one
of those undead. That would suck. You know
some of the main characters are going to get
turned. There are going to be some blue-eyed
main characters running around. And, god,
I hope it's not me."
Some fans, though, think that Catelyn has
already re-appeared as Lady Stoneheart in
season 7, passing through the background of
a scene at Winterfell at the same moment her
daughter, Arya, mentioned her.
"You swore to serve both my mother's daughters,
didn't you?"
And others believe the first season 8 teaser,
which shows the Stark children gathered in
the family crypt, hints at Catelyn's return.
"all the horror that has come to my family,
it's all because I couldn't love a motherless
child."
But It still seems pretty unlikely that Catelyn
will ever return. Don't worry, though. Game
of Thrones has plenty of big fish to fry,
dangling plot threads to tie up, and mysteries
to solve in its final six episodes — so
even if Cat never makes a surprise return,
viewers will have lots of juicy storylines
to sink their teeth into when season 8 premieres
on HBO on Sunday, April 14.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon. Subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one.